hi my name is RuPaul Galindo speaking
from the World Economic Forum video on
the country manners of British Telecom
thanks for the questions asked I'm going
to address the question is youth
participation important to the economic
developer love America the answer is
absolutely yes because of the energy the
passion and fresh new ideas they are
young generation bring to the table and
inspires all the rest of the society the
second question is how should you young
people get involved well first of all
investing on yourself in your own
education do what you like but work hard
become a skilled person and become a
very good professional second fostering
the best values possible honesty
integrity support for your colleagues
and friends foster them good citizenship
in third become mobilized organizing
groups organized in your community in
your families and support the ones that
are in most need one of the things in
Latin America is poetry so we need to
frost a social inclusion and I think the
young generation has a pivotal role on
actually putting Latin America what it
deserves to be thanks for the question
have a good one